Aaron Samson here to get you started in
watch dogs multiplayer online decryption
though alright watch dogs multiplayer
let's get you fired off have you get
past this minigame the starting the game
minigame mother let's get you um bud
trying to launch watchdogs mother jiggle
okay watch dogs multiplayer vehicle
mayhem a Palooza let's start with the
first question why should you take time
out of your busy Aiden Pearce schedule
of hacking rabbids foul mouth salmon or
fork lifting your own car repeatedly
yeah looks like this is over before it
really started well for starters you can
level up Aiden skills like a boss before
ever taking on the game's various
chronic [ __ ] before you hop into
multiplayer though the first upgrade you
should consider is a combat skill called
focus disability slows time and single
player and acts as a type of player
radar in multiplayer by outlining foes
even when they're behind cover after
that focus on hacking skills such as
traffic lights bollards and bridges
which you will need to make a hasty
escape also keep an eye on the separate
notoriety skill tree that levels up
through online play the first unlock
increases damage vs VA holes which is
something you want now for the rundown
online decryption mode pics 3 to 8
players against one another in both
teams and riding solo it's also one of
the modes you can get into right away
without having to play much of the
campaign regardless of the setup the
premise is this there's a cell phone
that everyone wants to get their hands
on because it's got some sick mp3s on it
or something capture and hold it long
enough to decrypt it and win you can
capture the celly by either killing the
guy or gal holding it or simply tailing
them long enough to steal it wirelessly
one of the most important things you can
do in this mode is get your hands on a
fast car it's not worth going after the
cell if you can't either make a fast
getaway once you get it or keep up with
the current phone carrier so again step
1 get a fast car
step 2 if you're playing with a team get
someone else in the car when you're
driving you cannot shoot but a passenger
can henceforth the car with the
passenger wins either when chasing or
being chased we did see if you crafty
players with full cars put one on the
roof not sure that's supposed to be a
thing but it still works even though the
driver can't shoot they're not helpless
though they can hack in world obstacles
or initiate abilities such as black out
and jam coms to buy getaway time
regardless if you're chasing and don't
have a passenger keep your distance and
steal the cell phone remotely rather
than risk getting shot up another good
tactic once you have the cell phone in
this mode is to take your team to the
edges of the map and pull up just make
sure there's a barrier between you and
the enemy or you will find yourself all
up in a cars grill as you play you will
unlock new loadouts balance precision
and sniper are there from the start
firepower heavy duty and Chicago Way
open up after that if you flip to the
online contracts menu you'll see a host
of guns you can unlock through online
decryption hacking racing and tailing
multiplayer modes these new loadouts
have some interesting weapons but their
usefulness is questionable the grenade
launcher for example from the firepower
loadout is great for juggling players at
the end of a round and can destroy
certain types of cover but doesn't have
a big enough blast radius or do enough
damage reverse cars to be recommended
the tommy gun from the Chicago Way
loadout also looks great but barks a lot
louder than advice honestly you'll be
fine if you just stick with the balanced
load out if you're really good you can
set up an IED from say the precision
loadout get the cell phone and then lead
your foes into a trap next let's talk
about some general driving combat tips
for starters be the first out of a car
or don't get out at all when doing a
vehicular manslaughter it often takes
hitting a player twice to kill them so
run them over then quickly flip it
reverse and run them over again if your
foe has a cell and gets into a car first
blowout the tires to make sure you can
catch up with them if you don't feel
like you can make an immediate kill shot
finally learn the rules of the
watchdog's world you can drive through
most things but trees and tall hedges
are indestructible you can also snap the
cover on some
things but not others using a car for
cover may leave parts of your body
hanging out just to be shot you can take
cover behind a porta potty but someone
can blow it up knowing what you can
climb or not is a matter of winning or
losing in decryption mode oh and go
crazy on the driving going upstairs
legit making a jump to the train tracks
legit you get the idea so share your
thoughts on watch dogs multiplayer are
you an online decryption mode or
spending all your time tailing other
players in 1v1 matches let us know what
you think in the comments below and
we'll see you out in Chicago and
probably